i do want to show you after 32 years
and seven months as a member of the
metro police department
there's just so much only a hint of
assistant sheriff ray flynn's new york
accent remains
teased out of any claims by training
officers who demanded his passport
i learned very quickly when in rome news
the romans do
when his home state wasn't hiring in
1980 the kid who always wanted to be a
cop answered his calling in southern
nevada
metro told him if he could get here in
four days he had a job so it was the
craziest thing i ever did
i gave my bosses three days notice and
bought a plane ticket and came out here
and it's been a
phenomenal roller coaster ride since
during his first year flynn worked foot
patrol on fremont street where
communications happened by call box with
a rotary phone
from the beat to the bark flynn became
metro's first mcgruff the crime dog
and later a k-9 officer with a
four-footed partner named donco
then in 1987 as a patrol sergeant on the
graveyard shift
the then father of three now four
attended another delivery
this one in the back seat of a 1968
rambler
sergeant ray flynn helped deliver
angelina he and the baby's mother join
us now from henderson
to talk about this experience of a
lifetime
woman starts yelling frantically help
help my daughter's gonna have a baby
we weren't trained to deliver babies but
we were trained
to make people feel safe making people
safe has been flynn's life's work
whether as a swat commander a hostage
negotiator or as a member of the
executive staff for three
of the five sheriffs he served even the
bad guys got flynn's consideration
like the hostage taker he talked out of
a bank for a big gulp
and a hug one thing you learn as a
hostile negotiator always keep your word
and he was not going to go in a patrol
car until he had a chance to hug me
so i'm surrounded by all these swat guys
that are going to protect me if anything
goes wrong
but but i did hug him flynn's metro
career has evolved with the department
from a small town police force to one of
the 10 largest police departments in the
country
when i look back i mean it was it was
almost like the old west compared to
where we are today
we've had phenomenal growth when i hired
on the total
number of employees was about 800 and
some odd
today we're over 5 000. though flynn is
reluctant to take credit for much of
anything
his boss and friend sheriff doug
gillespie searches for the right words
to express his contributions
you know i get a little uh
i'm going to miss ray for 32 years and
and seven months he has lived and
breathed
las vegas metropolitan police department
and keeping this community safe
and you just don't replace that flynn
leaves metro with scrapbooks of history
filled with presidents celebrities and
lots and lots of fellow officers
as he reflects on a life of service
flynn retires friday
with the same enthusiasm he felt on the
day he became a metro police officer
i've got great memories and it's time to
enter into
another chapter of my life i have no
firm ideas
what i'm going to do i'm going to travel